when i was 12 years old i went on
vacation to alaska with my family while
walking down one of the cold stone
covered beaches i spotted a large pile
of rocks that seemed to have slid off
the side of one of the hills that
connected to the shore these rocks
caught my eye due to their peculiar
outer rust color that contrasted with
the rest of the rocks on the beach
as i began curiously looking through
them i accidentally knocked a few over
splitting some in the process
but to my surprise one of the rocks that
split in half had a secret hidden within
it
inside were the imprints of a tiny
pinecone and nearby was a rock covered
in the imprints of leaves i was so
excited because that day i'd found real
plant fossils
but what exactly are fossils and what
can they tell us
fossils are preserved evidence of
organisms that lived in the distant past
they can be made up of many different
things like bones shells plants or even
markings like footprints that tell us
about an organism's behaviors
these preserved remains are mostly made
possible by a specific kind of rock
known as sedimentary rock
sedimentary rock is formed from
compressed layers of sediment which is a
mixture of rocks minerals and organic
matter
sediment is the result of erosion which
is when bits of rock or soil break down
and get deposited somewhere else
sediment is deposited in layers one on
top of the other
over millions of years these layers
become compressed eventually solidifying
and forming sedimentary rock
but how do the fossils even get inside
of these rocks well let's look back at
the fossil i found
if i had to guess a long time ago some
leaves and a pine cone must have fallen
to the ground and gotten covered in
sediment
as more sediment layered on top of them
the plants pressed an imprint of their
shape and patterns into the sediment
over time the sediment compressed into
rock and the original plant decayed but
its imprint stayed inside the rock
then finally my fossils sat until i
literally stumbled upon it
so now that we know what fossils are
what can they tell us
as i mentioned before fossils are like
little time machines that can show us
what types of organisms where alive
millions or even billions of years ago
and they can show us how life on earth
has changed over time but in order to
unlock these secrets scientists have to
estimate the ages of the fossils they
find this can be done in two main ways
either by looking at which layers of the
sedimentary rock the fossils are found
in or by using a process known as
radiometric dating let's talk about
layer analysis first as you know
sedimentary rocks are formed in layers
with each new layer forming on top of an
old layer
this means that the layers that are
closer to the surface tend to be newer
than the layers that are deeper in the
ground
this means that a fossil found in a
deeper layer of undisturbed sedimentary
rock will be older than the ones found
closer to the top by looking through
these layers we're able to not only tell
how old a particular fossil may be but
we can also look into the patterns of
fossils over multiple layers to see how
life on earth has changed over time
the second way scientists estimate a
fossil's age is through a process known
as radiometric dating radiometric dating
tells us how old a fossil is by studying
its chemical properties
specifically radiometric dating looks at
the decay or the loss of particles from
certain radioactive atoms in the fossils
scientists know how fast this decay
happens so by measuring the amount of
decay that has occurred scientists can
estimate the age of the fossil
once scientists know how old the fossil
is it can then be added to earth's
fossil record earth's fossil record
consists of all the fossils found on
earth along with their relative ages and
it provides us with the big picture view
of the history of life on earth and with
that you now know how fossils are formed
and dated let's go back through the
layers of this lesson and go over what
we've learned today
fossils are preserved evidence of
organisms that lived long ago
this evidence of life is most commonly
found in layers of sedimentary rock
now depending on how deep they are in
the layers of sedimentary rock or their
results from radiometric dating fossils
can be given an estimated age and be
placed on earth's fossil record
now when it comes to the fossil i found
it wasn't a major discovery like the
discoveries of the ichthyosaur and
plesiosaur fossils found by
paleontologists mary anning
but it made me realize that discovering
fossils is not carried out strictly by
professional scientists you and i can
both find fossils too all we need is a
keen eye some patience and maybe a
little bit of luck